I received my histamine scavenger but the dosage says one a day so don't take the dosage that's on the bottle take the dosage that I recommended and I can't remember what it is on to pull up your file and I can email it to you again.
Is there a specific time or between meals or more than once a day so typically with histamine scavenger so remember last week I talked about the different histamine reducing products so histamine scavenger is a really my favorite blend of different nutrients that could reduce histamine in the tissues.
It is our best selling histamine reducing products so people are having success with it we have people that buy it every single month that are patients so it's a it's a group I mean people like the product.
So this is something you can take it with a meal because it's not really working in the gut per se and it's you're not going to have any competition with absorption with something that you eat.
So that really doesn't make any difference whether you take it with a meal or take it between meals but like a nutrient if you want to keep a dosage in the blood you have to break it up during the day if you're going to just take two a day you take one of the morning one of the evening typically people take histamine scavenger taking three a day and they're split it up as best as they can.
Because remember everything has a half light all these nutrients have a half life in your blood so if you took all your supplements at seven o'clock in the morning when you wake up you're not going to have a whole lot circulated in your blood in the late evening it's you know a lot of that is gone and you're not getting the benefit of them so you want to break up your supplements.
We address this with stimulating you know try to get your immune system up is that you just stimulate your immune system through those means and you because your immune system is suppressed because of your type of cancer still you want to boost that through boosting your parasympathetics as well.
Late let's actually went up that's good heable global study at 13 red blood cell okay so those are all good so when you see this blood test normal acidic normal crowback that means it's you know the right size and the right color and everything is good.
Otherwise they'd have some suggestions for you I also have extra time during the day to run other additional life programs I would be ready just you know given given this fact that your white blood cells are still low I would just be running your cancer programs that I created so you can run your day cancer program that I created for you or you could run the night that night program just run it again.
I also started low dose delta exo at 0.5 milligrams will go up on stages see the better night sleep hopefully get up to three milligrams good doing coffee out of us twice a week okay so if you really want benefits from coffee out of us yeah got to get to do it daily so I know it's don't be likes to hear that but you want that stimulation do it daily.
Max Gerson his sickest patients you would make him do five coffee in him is a day five coffee in him is a day holy cow he'll make it any friends would you ask people to do that.